It's been a couple of weeks, but it is time
for hatriot mail. What is hatriot mail? Here's
a reminder.
If you're allowed to shop for luxuries like
food and medicine, then we should be allowed
to clap our hands together in a megachurch
teary eyed man written by patriots who hey
David Pakman because of America and because
freedom.
This one is pretty brutal. This one's pretty
brutal. The anti-Semitism is back in full
swing. Take a look.
If you're allowed to shop for luxuries like
food and medicine, then we should be allowed
to clap our hands together in a megachurch.
Pay tribute memo written by patriots who hate
David Pakman because of America and because
freedom.
I'm more tired of this Jew David Pakman than
I've ever been. Why are Jews so opinionated?
One Jew. Two opinions. Two Jews. Four opinions.
Four Jews. Eight opinions. Exponent Jew. But
this guy is a denier of Christ. So of goes
with the territory. A Jew from Argentina.
Imagine that trespass, sir. On top of everything
else. I admit though. Hispanic Ashkenazy.
He's damn handsome. Hate him though.
This person seems strangely attracted to me
despite their anti-Semitism. That that's kind
of different. I guess the hate mail lately
that I've been getting, it's a lot of masking
economy stuff. It's kind of conspiratorial.
It's overwhelmingly, you know, I'm part of
some conspiracy to shut down the economy to
hurt Donald Trump. Corona virus is a hoax.
Masks don't do anything or may actually be
killing people. That's been a lot of it. And
no good conspiracy theory in the United States
is missing anti-Semitism. So a lot of it is
tied into it's the Jews who want people wearing
masks or it's the Jews who want to shut down
the economy or whatever. It's very, very vile
stuff. But remember that you can fight hatriot
CISM by using the coupon code hatriot 40 to
get a 40 percent discount off of the membership
of your choice at join Pacman dot com. You
save 40 percent with the coupon code hatriot
40, the hatriot cry. An independent media
benefits that spelled h a t r i o t for zero.